بقينا في الدره والحرب وصار القصف واشتد
الشي اول ما اجينا قعدنا في
مدرسه الفخوره صار كل يوم الثاني وهم
يخبطوا فيها اخر مره استشهد فيها السلف
وصار شهد كثير منها وخبطو وشرنا منها
وجينا هنا صار يخبطوا علينا هنا
وطردونا وصار شهداء ومن رغم هيك هيك يعني
وين ما نروح يعني الوضع السيء وغزه ما
صارت غزه غزه تدمرت يعني وين بدنا نروح
يعني الحياه بدها تمشي يعني بدهاش تقف
يعني وين بدنا نروح وين بنا نسكن في
الشوارع هيك هيك مدمره مدمره بدنا نقعد
احنا بدنا نعيش احنا
نفسنا نحل من هل احنا فيه لكن صحيح السقعه
راح تاكلنا وال وراح نمشي على الوسخ اللي
احنا فيه هذا على التسمم وع القرف بس ايش
بدنا نسوي يعني احنا ننتخب قاعدين من
الوضع من القصف ومن الحروب هذ احنا تعبنا
تعبنا خايفه عليها خايفه عليها كثير خايفه
عليها من هال التصمم اللي احنا فيه وكمان
بتضلها كثيره حتى بتبقى تصحى من النوم فاز
من الصوت يما ي الحقلي من الصواريخ اللي
بقت تصير ومن الوضع اللي بق
يصير y